[Applause]
our first guest though knows a thing or
two about bestselling albums he's still
incredibly talented he sold over 75
million worldwide and won five Grammys
no big deal but now he's got a whiskey
it's called Fraser and Thompson and it's
available online and it's select Spirit
retailer so please welcome my my
[Music]
Bo
hi did you hear me say my way instead of
Michael but I like
it
everybody I love I love that it at least
happened with you cuz you're funny so I
was I literally instead of saying Cole I
said my bé instead of Michael you're now
mine yeah I want to be your I just
collected you I wanted
how are you hi Kelly Clarkson hi happy
New Year how was your New Year thank you
New Year's is great I did a show what
did you do uh I hung out with the family
I was in I was in Miami it was
amazing uh I have four I have four kids
four kids do you sleep do I sleep I've
had four kids in my household at once
before that's a lot I'm too busy making
kids yeah yeah congratulations on that
okay do you ever do y all make
resolutions or goals or anything do you
all do that yeah of course yeah okay
what are some of yours U Mine was go to
the gym every single day oh eat no more
like no more carbs no more sugars okay
um how long fa last yeah last it to like
the second yeah I don't even set that
goal anymore man I don't even know I'm
like don't why lie to myself yeah yeah I
could die tomorrow I'm gonna die with
sugar on my
[Music]
tongue
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home